lorsque vous me demander monsieur le
président si le gouvernement être
disponible pour répondre aux questions
disponibles pour entendre ce que lui
disent les représentants de la nation
réponse est évidemment oui
et pour tout vous dire monsieur le
président je me permets de m'étonner que
vous puissiez redouté franchement nous
avons ici eu des débats sérieux je crois
[Musique]
digne qui n'était pas d'ailleurs
nécessairement consensuel mais après
tout les débats sont là pour ça vous
l'avez rappelé mais je ne crois pas que
quiconque puisse dire que le
gouvernement aurait refusé de répondre à
des questions ne se serait pas mis à la
disposition n'aurait pas respecté les
commissions du sénat
le sens du débat que vous ne savez pas
d'accord avec toutes les réponses pour
l'entendre
ça c'est normal c'est la démocratie mais
ne laissons pas croire monsieur le
président à nos concitoyens que il y
aurait d'un côté ceux qui portent la
voix vivante de la démocratie et de
l'autre un gouvernement qui
ne voudrais pas l'entendre parce que ça
ne correspond pas à la vérité je crois
que vous le savez vous me posez avant de
poser la question de savoir si nous
étions disposés soucieux d'entendre ce
que le parlement a à dire est ce qu'il
souhaite faire prévaloir le parlement
dans son ensemble le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale
car ce sont les deux chambres qui font
la loi et aussi bien devons respecter le
sénat nous devons aussi respecter
l'assemblée nationale ne viendrait à
l'idée quiconque de penser que ça ne
devrait pas être le cas donc nous sommes
évidemment prêts à écouter à entendre à
nourrir le débat essayer d'apporter des
positions qui ont été retenues par le
gouvernement et à les confronter le cas
échéant avec le souhait de la
représentation nationale au sens le plus
large
vous avez indiqué voudrais simplement
dire d'un mot parce que vous avez évoqué
beaucoup de sujets dans le début de
votre question le fait que vous ne riez
pas
eu de réponse à la question de savoir si
la priorité c'était la santé ou la
reprise monsieur le président j'essaie
d'expliquer mais je conçois que ce soit
tellement difficile à expliquer que je
suis sans doute insuffisamment clair
j'ai essayé d'expliquer depuis deux
semaines que le chemin de crête sur
lequel nous nous trouvons est un chemin
qui nous impose de tenir un équilibre
entre la sécurité sanitaire et la
reprise entre les deux c'est un
équilibre
c'est toujours difficile de maintenir un
équilibre mais vous voyez bien et vous
savez pertinemment que si nous donnons
la priorité à l'un en oubliant l'autre
nous risquons de très mauvaises
nouvelles de très mauvaises nouvelles
vous savez parfaitement monsieur le
président la catastrophe sociale qui
s'annonce et qui serait encore pire si
nous restions indéfiniment confiné vous
le savez vous la vivez dans votre
département enfin tout le monde la vie
tout le monde l'assentiment de la voit
arriver nous devons donc reprendre la
production
nous devons donc reprendre la vie
sociale nous devons donc reprendre
l'école parce que sinon c'est la
catastrophe
et nous savons aussi que si nous allons
trop vite par enthousiasme par
imprudence en privilégiant cette fois ci
la reprise sur la sécurité sanitaire
nous risquons dans ce cas là de très
mauvaises nouvelles sanitaires pourquoi
monsieur le président présenter les
choses comme si nous avions délibérément
choisi une priorité par rapport à
l'autre nous essayons justement et ça
fait pas facile de garantir l'équilibré
entre ces deux principes et c'est un
chemin de crête c'est vrai avec 2 à pic
vertigineux et d'antoine crête
je pense que nous gagnerions tous parce
que la nation est confrontée à une vraie
difficulté à essayer de comprendre et
peut-être même monsieur le président
peut-être même d'expliquer la nécessité
de cet équilibre plutôt que de nous
accuser ce parfois d'aller trop d'un
côté parfois trop de l'autre on peut
évidemment discuter des déséquilibres
que nous essayons développer mais je
crois que nous avons tous intérêt
collectivement la nation intérêt à ce
qu'on explique la nécessité de préserver
cet équilibre
je le crois bien plus que simplement une
présentation de l'un ou de l'autre